grab your sniper rifle
episode 5 has infected running faster
than Pedro Pascal fans after watching
this clip hello I love you I'm just
gonna sit here and say I love you and
say hi and slay and yeah now that I've
subjected you to that we can get into
this week's Deep dive for those of you
new here welcome and for those coming
back why are you doing this to yourself
episode 5 actually begins 10 days before
the events of episode 4. fedger's been
kicked out of power by Kathleen and her
group of revolutionaries and these
revolutionaries are absolutely brutal
with public executions lynchings and
share music playing over the speakers in
the game we see similar bodies strung up
by the ruthless group known as the
hunters in Pittsburgh remember that in
the show Kansas City has replaced
Pittsburgh On The Run are Henry and his
younger brother Sam if you played the
game you'll immediately notice two big
changes first Sam is much younger in the
game he's closer to 13 instead of eight
so
how old are you me 14.
how old are you uh the same oh you're 14
huh I'm close sorry I need to see some
idea the writers also made him deaf now
as of the time of this writing they
haven't released the podcast which will
likely explain why they made these
choices but as a huge fan of the game I
personally think this worked pretty well
Kathleen scares the [__] out of a bunch
of collaborators these are men and women
who ratted out their neighbors to fedra
for perks such as hard to come by Foods
or medicine and you bet your ass I'd rat
my neighbors out if fidra had access to
new Last of Us episodes in this one we
learn a little more about Kathleen and
why she's become this ruthless almost
dictator-like figure her brother
considered by many to be a great man was
the leader of this resistance and
judging by his message of forgiveness he
likely had a very different way of
fighting against fedra's authoritarian
rule as Kathleen will later tell her
right-hand man Perry played here by the
same actor who portrayed Tommy in the
game her brother Michael didn't have
what it takes to actually get this
Revolution going it was only when she
took the reins after a his death that
they started to make Headway we also
find out that Michael was in prison and
was allowed to see family so it appears
that there was some sort of justice
system in place under Federal rule
remember the walls even had these
prisoner rights juxtaposed this to
Kathleen who tells all the collaborators
that after a fair trial they'll do some
time but in reality she's just going to
have them all killed and their bodies
burned in piles one of these piles we
see in the show and another in the game
ah I don't think these guys were
infected but there's one thing Kathleen
wants more than anything Henry he turned
her brother in in exchange for
life-saving medicine that could help
with Sam's leukemia later in the episode
Henry will disclose this to Joel and it
begs the question does doing a bad thing
make you a bad man Joel's someone who's
done tons of bad things but do we
consider him a bad person it's a
question that's been posed several times
throughout the season one of the
collaborators mentions Henry is with
Edelstein the doctor we met in episode
4. he's helped Henry and Sam find refuge
in a safe house that once belonged to
one of his patients a patient who is now
dead so Kathleen tasks her cronies with
finding Henry and Sam and you might
remember this guy as being the guard who
stood outside edelstein's cell in
episode 4. but Perry has some concerns
they've just overtaken the city and
there are far better ways they could be
spending their resources than tracking
down to civilians the same thing
happened in episode 4 Perry warned
Kathleen about the bloater problem but
she Shrugged it off telling him instead
to focus on Henry and Sam she has put
her personal Vendetta against Henry
ahead of the welfare of her people a
decision that will ultimately get her
and her followers killed the attic
Hideout looks a little different than
when we saw it in episode 4 no crayon
drawings on the wall or empty cans of
food this will change over the next 10
days as the three rash in the 20 cans of
food and six pounds of jerky Henry's
plan is to sneak out via the the tunnels
but Edelstein says he might as well just
kill himself those tunnels are
supposedly filled with infected remember
that test said infected love dark and
damp conditions so it kind of makes
sense and later on in the episode when
Henry explains his plan to Joel he
States the infected were driven
underground by fedra 15 years ago
everyone top side fears the tunnels and
won't go near them but a federal guy he
worked with told him they're completely
clean and you know if they're fedra It's
gotta be true Edelstein tells Henry that
Sam is scared because he's scared so
dequella's fears and draw his attention
away from the violence of the world he
gives him some crayons to liven up the
place alright
somebody drew a penis here he draws
Super Sam who fights off the evil fedra
forces ten days later the rations have
run out fedra is closing in on their
location and Edelstein has gone an
entire day looking for food and hasn't
returned we know from episode 4 that he
was somehow caught so Henry and Sam have
to make the harrowing decision to flee
or face starving to death luckily Henry
has been watching The Rebel patrols and
thinks he knows their patterns he paints
Sam's face giving him his own mask just
like super Sam my mask on their way out
Henry sees Joel and Ellie take on Brian
and the rebels at the laundromat an
event we saw last episode seeing this
from Henry's perspective serves two
important roles one that allows Henry to
see that Joel and Ellie are not with
Kathleen and two that Joel is adept with
a gun he'll later ask Joel to join him
in their escape since he'll be their
muscle I showed away
you clear the way this is the way Henry
has also never killed a man at least not
directly he'll open up to Joel and tell
him how he turned in Michael the leader
of the revolution in exchange for his
brother's medicine it's also ironic he
mentions not killing anyone since at the
end of the episode he'll end up killing
his brother and himself but more on that
in a bit we now come up to the final
moments of episode 4 where Sam and Henry
hold Joel and Ellie at gunpoint even
though Joel left glass on the ground to
alert them of intruders it's implied his
hearing is so bad in his right ear he
never heard them coming when he wakes
you'll see that he was sleeping on his
good ear and hints of his poor hearing
were set up in episode 4. The reason I
asked whether you'd hear the glass or
not because I've noticed you don't hear
Too Well from your right side the
initial confrontation between Henry and
Joel although tense is not as violent as
it is in the game
oh
shut up
that's because the game didn't have that
moment where Henry recognizes Joel and
Ellie as allies it's only when Henry
sees Ellie in the game that he knows
they're not with the rebels because he
States if you haven't noticed they don't
keep kids around the rebels in the game
also known as Hunters have a survival of
the fittest mentality and kids are seen
as weak this is perhaps what drove many
of the children underground as we'll see
in both the game and show these play
center type bunkers whether or not
Kathleen has adopted a similar stance on
children remains to be seen but we do
know that she has no problem killing
them well kids die Henry they die all
the time you crazy evil [__] in episode
4 we learned that Ellie was able to grab
some of Bill's food from the truck
before they fled which they share with a
gracious Sam and Henry by making their
way up the building they can get a
better view of the city and devise and
exit strategy similar to what they did
in episode 2 when making their plan to
cut through Boston in the game this
doesn't take place in Kansas City's
tallest building rather a safe house in
Pittsburgh now Henry catches Joel up to
speed on what happened to Kansas City
which he refers to as killer City if you
thought Boston Federal was bad the
federan KC makes Boston look like Sesame
Street Henry later telling Joel that 20
years of torture and murder will push
people to do unspeakable things Henry
also divulges that he's a collaborator
something Joel has great disdain for no
doubt he's seen how collaborators have
turned in many of his friends in the
past and again it's also a bit
hypocritical since he collaborated with
fedra to smuggle supplies although you
could argue that different collaborator
or not Joel needs Henry and Henry needs
Joel Henry shows how the city is
surrounded by patrolled highways and
trying to get past them would be suicide
hence He suggests using the city's
underground maintenance tunnels to sneak
past the patrols and make it to the
other side in the game they have to make
it past a fedra Outpost which guards
this huge Bridge there's even a nod to a
bridge in the show although much smaller
while Joel and Henry go over the plan
Ellie bonds with Sam laughing over her
book of puns in the game the two also
share a moment in which Henry remarks
it's good to hear that kind of laughter
again it's been a while since that boy
even cracked a smile Sam also has this
Woody Woodpecker magic slate which he
uses to communicate since Joel and Ellie
don't know sign language it's a way for
them to communicate with Sam especially
later on in the episode with scenes
between Ellie and Sam with no other
option the group takes on Henry's
dangerous plan enter the bank access the
tunnels reach the residential area and
cross the bridge Henry is a bit cocky
with his plan especially as as they
arrive in the tunnels and they're
seemingly empty see it's empty the plan
is good
Ellie even asked if there are any
clickers down here in Henry's surprise
when she says they took on two and
survived my favorite moment down here is
when Henry refers to Joel as Ellie's dad
and they both deny it at the same time
the two refused to see the
father-daughter connection that's
growing between them the tunnels lead
them to the entrance of an underground
settlement drawn to look like a castle
what happened here is one of the game's
most chilling Easter eggs we get a brief
glimpse of this drawing of Danny and ish
Protectors of the Underground through a
series of notes found in the game we
learn of isha's story a man who was at
Sea during the initial outbreak and was
forced ashore near the sewers of
Pittsburgh ish is a reference to the
main character in The 1949 novel Earth
abides in which isherwood Williams
establishes a community of pandemic
survivors ish being a sea captain also
Bears a resemblance to Ishmael the main
character in Herman Melville's Moby Dick
so ish constructed his own safehouse and
in need of supplies searched the nearby
suburbs where he found family Susan Kyle
and their children they joined him in
his safe house and pretty soon they
started a thriving Community with its
own school and Rain catchers which can
be seen here in the show there are a ton
of similarities from this soccer net to
a list of house rules Ellie questions
what happened to them and Joel States
maybe they didn't follow the rules and
they all got infected I found this
rather interesting since Ellie hasn't
followed Jules rules he outlined in
episode 3 she didn't listen to him by
keeping her gun in her jacket instead of
the backpack like he asked and she'll
break his second rule later in the
episode by showing Sam her condition
well too you don't tell anyone about
your
condition it was issue allowed the kids
to paint the front entrance to look like
a castle and sometime thereafter he met
Danny and the two became the Protectors
of the community collecting weapons and
armor from dead soldiers but things took
a horrific turn when the door leading to
the safe house was accidentally left
open allowing a horde of infected to run
in in the game we see the tunnels filled
with infected from this settlement I
guess we know what happened
so you know there was a clicker they've
been gone for a while the fate of ish
however is left unknown he survived the
initial attack on the safe house but
what exactly happened to him is a
mystery Sam finds a Savage Starlight
comic this is a collectible you can find
throughout the game and one of Ellie's
favorites in fact she mentions it right
before they get to Pittsburgh I know it
doesn't look like it but this here is
not a bad read only one problem
right there to be continued its motto is
quote to the edge of the universe and
back endure and survive endure and
survive being the title of this episode
and my motto after I finish an entire
Taco Bell family meal to myself fun fact
the Savage Starlight comic is published
by Dark Horse which is the same company
that publishes The Last of Us American
Dreams Henry opens up to Joel about
being a collaborator having to turn in a
great man to save the life of his
brother he calls Michael a man who is
never afraid or selfish always forgiving
a man you'd follow anywhere have you
ever met someone like that I wonder if
Joel is thinking of Tommy here a man he
literally follows everywhere Henry also
senses Joel was once a father he has
that protective Instinct he might not be
her father
she was so much speaking of children
Kathleen reflects in her childhood
bedroom one she shared with her brother
it was her safe space and so long as she
was there with him nothing could hurt
her but Michael is gone and she makes
abundantly clear to Perry she is not
Michael if Michael were kind and
forgiving she is not forgiveness does
not win revolutions and that's part of
the reason Perry and the others follow
her she got [__] done so even though her
brother would have wanted her to forgive
Henry her sense of justice or Revenge
rather clouds her judgment meanwhile
Henry Joel Sam and Ellie make it through
the tunnels and into the nearby
residential area Henry's a bit cocky
about how his planned work I'm just
saying I delivered
similar to the game yup what'd I tell
you huh in the game this whole section
is much longer with the team spending
more time exploring the abandoned homes
of Pittsburgh you'll even see this
graffiti on the front doors just like
fedra painted on the homes in Lincoln if
you look even closer you'll find giraffe
Easter eggs we've already seen one in
episode 2 which hints at one of the
game's most iconic scenes even though
they've made it to the other side they
need to keep their flashlights off so as
to not draw attention which is a good
idea considering what's about to happen
now at this point it's unclear where
Henry and Sam will go after they reach
the bridge in the game they're headed
toward a military radio station where
Henry was to meet up with some survivors
these survivors never show up Ellie
suggests they come with them to Wyoming
which Joel isn't too pleased about but
as Ellie suggests she'll wear him down
until he says yes persistence is a trait
both Ellie and Joel possess when it
comes to his brother Joel says what if
you don't find him I will how do you
know I'm persistent the group's Luck run
drives when they're attacked by a sniper
luckily they this guy misses more than
me at the bar one of the moments I found
interesting here is Henry and Sam
attempting to run away the game takes
this a step further with them actually
abandoning Joel and Ellie to save
themselves something Joel doesn't take
too calmly to when they later reunite it
should be noted that in the game Henry
saves Joel and Ellie after they nearly
drowned after escaping the hunters from
the bridge which kinda makes up for this
abandonment in both versions Joel flanks
the sniper but in the show this sniper
is an old man whereas in the game it's
someone much younger and I really like
this change his old age might explain
why his shot was so bad and why he was
given this shitty Duty we'll see that
he's working for Kathleen and they
probably put this guy out here not
expecting Joel and Henry would be coming
this way now Joel could have just killed
this man right away but he doesn't I've
always seen Joel as a character who more
or less does bad things for good reasons
so when he ends up killing the old man
it's because his own life and others are
in Jeopardy he gave the old man the
option to put his gun down and let them
leave peacefully but he doesn't whether
this is because he fears he'll die
anyway should Kathleen find he let them
go we'll never really know unfortunately
the man had already radioed into
Kathleen that their fugitives had been
found with her telling him to hold on to
them until they arrive we'll see
Kathleen's crew led by this giant truck
festooned with a plow to move cars and
trucks out of the way something Joel sen
happened on the road outside the gas
station in episode 4. it's pretty funny
that the plow says run as it chases down
Henry Sam and Ellie in both versions
Joel uses his vantage point from The
sniper's Nest to fend off this vehicle
but in the video game he shoots a guy
trying to light a Molotov cocktail and
it explodes inside the truck ramming it
into a nearby house in the show Joel
shoots the driver it crashes and the gas
canister lights on fire causing a
similar explosion with nowhere to go and
Kathleen stating that salmonelli will
not be spared Henry tells Ellie and Sam
to run while he turns himself in and it
looks as though All Is Lost for Henry
when suddenly the truck sinks into the
ground like the pile of rubble within
the city something lurks Underground not
only a swath of infected and clickers
but even the rarest of all infected a
bloater now this was absolutely
terrifying the infected come out with
alarming speed and numbers it almost
reminded me of the zombies in World War
Z even with their Superior Firepower
it's not long before the rebels are
quickly overrun this Pillsbury Doughboy
looking character is the bloater this is
what happens when you've been infected
with cordyceps for several years over
time a thick fungus develops over their
skin which acts like armor making
Conventional Weapons ineffective if only
Perry knew to throw a Molotov cocktail
bloaters are actually susceptible to
fire Perry dies here just like some of
the bloater death animations in the game
with the bloater grabbing his jaw and
ripping apart his head in all the
commotion Joel tries his best to pick
off any infected around Ellie she finds
refuge in the back of a car when a girl
clicker makes its way inside she's even
got a Blues Clues shirt on it's totally
possible that this girl was part of that
underground School Ellie escapes to find
Henry and Sam pinned by two Clickers
which he makes quick work of using the
switchblade given to her by Marlene one
of the comics we learned was given to
her by Ellie's mother although never
shown it's roughly around this time that
Sam is bitten something he'll later
reveal to Ellie as they make their
escape toward the bridge they're stopped
by Kathleen even with everything going
on around them Kathleen wants one thing
Henry but she's made quick work of when
the clicker girl pounces on her and
shreds her to bits I guess Kathleen was
right it ends the way it ends with the
group making their escape we hear the
bloater making this large guttural growl
almost as if he's leading the infected
toward their next stop Kansas City in an
abandoned Motel Joel Henry salmonelli
take refuge after the night's harrowing
events Ellie and Sam read a Savage
Starlight comic while Joel says Henry
and Sam can join them on their journey
to Wyoming Henry says he'll share the
good news with Sam in the morning making
Sam's death ever the more tragic Sam
asks Ellie what she's scared of
something that's brought up in the game
scorpions are pretty creepy
scorpions Ellie opens up to Sam about
her true fear ending up alone remember
that Ellie has been alone her entire
life growing up as an orphan at a
federal facility everyone she's been
close to in life has either died or
abandoned her including Riley who we
haven't yet seen in the show so this is
a very real fear for her Ellie then asks
Sam what his fear is answering if you
turn into a monster is it still inside
you this is similar to what he says in
the game one of the people are still
inside
what if they're trapped in there without
any control of their body this prompts
Sam to show Ellie his bite mark remember
from episode 1 that a bite to the leg
can take anywhere from 12 to 24 hours to
take control and we can already see it
started to spread now Ellie doesn't tell
Joel or Henry instead she breaks the
second rule and shows Sam her condition
and attempts to heal him by using her
own blood she writes my blood is
medicine cuts her hand and places it on
his wound with the hopes it might save
him he asked her to stay awake with him
and she says I promise this is why
she'll later write I'm sorry on the
magic pad because she fell asleep in his
final moments in the game Ellie's in a
different room than Sam and is asked to
check up on him for breakfast before
she's attacked in fact in the game Sam
never discloses his bite to her they
also cut out a section where Sam asked
if she believes in heaven which she says
she does not what happens next plays out
relatively the same in both versions
with one exception Sam attacks Ellie
Henry won't let Joel save Ellie Henry
shoots Sam then Henry shoots himself elf
the exception here is what Henry says to
Joel when he briefly points the gun at
him with the game version having Henry
claim Joel is responsible
this is nobody's fault him
it adds a beat of tension before Henry
ultimately shoots himself perhaps
Kathleen was right this is what happens
when you [__] with fate the game cuts to
Black preparing us for the next section
of the game while the show gives us a
brief epilogue where Joel and Ellie bury
the dead Agnes obel's fueled to the
fireplace as the credit rolls a song
about grief which asks if it's better to
dwell on the past or forge on ahead it
looks like our protagonists are moving
on to whatever awaits them in Wyoming
but what did you think of episode 5 I
want to hear your thoughts and theories
in the comments below thanks for
watching everyone be sure to like And
subscribe and for more bad takes you can
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at
thinkstoryyt until next time remember
hello I love you I'm just gonna sit here
and say I love you and say hi and slay
and yes